I do believe that Iraq has been an
obsession of the United States now for
almost 20 years and one of the things we
try to do in the book is show that Iraq
is not a post 2003 problem it's been
there since saddam hussein invaded
kuwait in august of 1990 and you had
george HW bush reversing that invasion
with a coalition under the authorization
of the United Nations hugely successful
Gulf War he had ninety percent approval
rating which then evaporates as the
campaign goes on because people aren't
you know went that appreciative once the
whole thing is over he did not decide to
send American troops to Baghdad to
topple Saddam Hussein so Saddam remains
in power and the Clinton administration
for eight years tries to figure out what
to do with that regime there's an
international sanctions regime to
prevent Saddam Hussein from building
weapons of mass destruction the United
States is patrolling no-fly zones in the
north and south to protect populations
in Iraq from the regime in Baghdad when
we spoke to Madeleine Albright who was
the UN ambassador in the first Clinton
term she said her whole time is un
ambassador was spent dealing with
resolution if the resolution on Iraq
because they were the resolutions that
ended the Persian Gulf War were
constantly coming up for renewal and she
had to keep the coalition together and
so there was this huge amount of
attention paid to Iraq through the
period Bill Clinton told george w bush
that he regretted not being able to do
something about saddam hussein and of
course George W Bush is going to hand
off the Iraq problem to his successor
it'll be the third Iraq handoff and you
know it is while in racks an important
country in an important region it has
distorted American foreign policy there
are lots of other big problems out there
during this past 20 years we've seen the
rise of China for example in general the
rise of Asia and we're really under
equipped as a nation to think about
these proud
them strategically we haven't thought
through these problems and these are the
kinds of things the rise of Asia climate
change these are the things that are
going to dominate our world in the
coming decades and we've been distracted
by our entanglement in Iraq
you